the president meeting with the Saudi
Crown Prince at the White House today
but the headline ended up being his call
with Vladimir Putin congratulating the
Russian leader on his election win which
was not a surprise but got a lot of
reaction in here in Washington and in
Arizona there's Senator McCain's
statement an American president does not
lead the free world by congratulating
dictators on winning sham elections and
by doing so with Latimer Putin President
Trump insulted every Russian citizen who
was denied the right to vote in a free
and fair election to determine their
country's future including the countless
Russian Patriots who have risked so much
to protest and resist Putin's regime
with that let's bring in our panel jonah
goldberg senior editor at National
Review Amy Walter national editor for
the cook Political Report and Ben
Dominic's publisher at the Federalist
Ben thoughts on the reaction a lot of it
here in Washington to this statement and
this communication well it's a different
situation now in terms of our
relationship with Russia than it was
several years ago when we saw President
Obama giving congratulations to Putin
over this over a recent election this is
a situation that I think is it's going
to turn into its own sort of form of a
reset we're an attempt by the Trump
administration to engage in that
behavior obviously they want to get rid
of this investigation that has been
ongoing they want it to come to a
conclusion and they want to talk to
Putin about a number of different
factors but the domestic scenario here
the situation in Washington really
hasn't allowed them to do that yet it is
very different from the time of Obama
and even very different from just a
couple of months ago because this is no
longer just simply about Russia meddling
in the election we're now talking about
poisoning of in Britain we are you know
we have not had discussions yet on that
and apparently the President did not
raise that issue with Putin so I think
this is one of those issues it has been
ongoing since the president has gotten
into town that divides the Republican
Party much the way that the issue of
trade divides the party that you're
going to have folks in the camp that say
that there should be absolutely no
relationship with Putin he's a bad dude
we should always see him as a bad dude
don't ever try to make this relationship
work
folks that are aligned with the
president who do want to see something
happening but the bottom line is there's
a whole lot that has happened even in
the last couple of months that the fact
that the president didn't raise that I
think is a good part of the reason why
so many Republicans are worried I mean
he's talking about the the poisoning in
Great Britain or the the sanctions that
this regime this regime this
administration has put on the Russian
regime doesn't talk about that right now
there's this weird double game going on
where the administration actually has
been quite tough on on Russia Dom Trump
hasn't been rhetorically and it sets off
it sets people off around Washington
because of all the other baggage that we
were referring to here I agree a lot of
things have changed one thing hasn't
changed Russia is not a democracy and I
didn't like it when Barack Obama talked
about you know congratulated Vladimir
Putin I don't like it when Donald Trump
does it for the simple reason I don't
like it when Sarah Sanders says we can't
dictate how they do things in Russia
we're not done dictating we're just
about bearing witness to the truth which
is that it's a dictatorship
it's an authoritarian regime and this
was a sham election and America was
supposed to stand for some of that stuff
like you know you point out that this
regime that the Russian regime is facing
a lot of sanctions yeah from the US I
agree it's this weird thing it's it's
it's almost like just Trump can't bring
himself to say the words maybe because
he doesn't care about this rhetorical
niceties maybe because he has this idea
about having a relationship with Putin
maybe just because he wants to see
people's heads explode on MSNBC I mean
III maybe all of the above but you know
rhetoric matters and telling the truth
about this regime is worthwhile I want
to turn to domestic politics now a lot
hangs in the balance government funding
is there a dock a deal let's let's
listen to the dacha deal back and forth
the deal that was offered earlier this
week included a three-year extension for
dacha in exchange for the water wall and
border security funding
probably favored a short-term solution
three years for three years I just had a
meeting with a variety of senators who
seemed surprised that some of the offers
made by the administration were rejected
out of hand but there were going to be
lots of opportunities for us to try and
help the doctor kids right now the
president as he did a few weeks ago was
standing in the way but is it fair to
say that because you know the president
says it's the Democrats who don't want
to take this deal they want it as a as
an election issue I think the Democrats
clearly do want it as an election issue
but in addition to that I think you have
a situation here where we're dealing
with a bill that is complete a complete
mess I mean it has all these different
priorities smashed into it in different
ways that don't fit we're still seeing a
couple of those come to light I don't
think there is any real chance of a deal
at this juncture just given the politics
of this issue and it's only going to
continue to be demagogued as as we go
forward the reality is that earlier in
the show you know they were talking
about well this is the John Cornyn was
saying that you know this is the way
that business works now and then things
can't really work well guess what that's
what things are going to look like for
the future forever unless we have a
fundamental change in the way that the
Senate and the Congress behaves Amy what
about funding I mean is probably gonna
have a snow day tomorrow yes which means
that the week gets shorter right and
probably into the weekend yes I don't
think we're gonna see a government
shutdown but I agree with Ben that what
we are gonna see is sort of a big mess
of a bill with nobody getting really the
priorities that they really truly wanted
to see out of this conservatives are
gonna be upset at some of these things
obviously Democrats are going to be
upset we have this funding for a project
in New York that the president's very
upset with that a lot of folks in New
York wanted to see but the but the
bottom line really is that this is it
this is the last piece of legislating
we're gonna see I think for all the rest
of the year so whatever gets done in
this bill is what's gonna get done and
if not well guess what gotta wait till
2019 huge gamble to on the part of
Republicans to do that basically saying
we're going to rest on our laurels bill
and that same this is why people hate
Washington and - one of the reasons